[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
well okay most of that was true my name
is actually alex mollering and caleb has
bravely appointed me as this evening's
driver
well my current rating is only about
1400
i do hope to provide a unique
perspective as i myself am on the road
to 2000
so tonight i would like to take this
opportunity to stroke my own ego and
showcase some highlights from my chest
career tonight it's all about alex
i'm only sort of kidding
chess compels me for many reasons but
one of the most significant is its
capacity as a narrative device
the mythos surrounding legendary chess
figures surprising encounters climactic
victories unforgettable blunders
and the evolutionary history of the game
intrigues me and many others
game titles like morphe's opera house
and the game of the century convey this
uh
narrative weight
as does the thematic conflict between
man and machine as seen when kasparov
faced off against deep blue and won
and then later lost
alpha zero's explosive and stylistic
annihilation of stockfish reignited
passion for the romantic ideals of chess
seen in the old days through players
like mikhail tal
and while this use of game as a
storytelling device isn't unique to
chess it happens in lots of games and
sports
chess has something about it that
conveys this even at a meta level
because chess broken down to its
quintessential elements
is a war of ideas played out over 64
squares
some ideas are stronger than others some
are unsound but frequently trick
unprepared opponents and some have stood
the test of time
tonight i would like to explore this
concept with you by using the games and
story that i know best
and those are my own
so
to do so why don't we start by looking
at some puzzles some games that i've
played and some kind of special moments
from them and i'm going to do so in a
story format
in november 2012 i was a sophomore in
high school and i was playing in a
tournament against a rival
now this guy was about
400 500 rating points higher than i was
at the time so i went into that game
expecting a tough battle and i was not
disappointed
he won a hard-fought game after 52 long
moves but after going back to analyze
the game i realized i had missed a
crushing move near the beginning so
we're going to take a look at this game
just the beginning of it and see if we
can find
a better idea than what i played in the
game
so i had the white pieces here and the
game started out with e4
my opponent played a
g6 so we have a modern defense d4 bishop
to g7
bishop to g5
pinning this e pawn to the queen d6
bishop to e3 or sorry to e2 and my idea
was maybe if i have a quick commitment
to castling from my opponent i might try
some kind of pawn storm with h4h5 maybe
maybe h3g4 unclear but that was kind of
my ideas maybe even just f4 right away
but waiting to see what my opponent did
but he didn't go for this kind of
commitment to castling he instead plays
knight d7
i played knight to c3 and c5 striking in
the center
and now i have to defend so i played
just knight f3 simple development
queen to b6 continuing the attack also
attacking down here at
b2
and in this position i thought for some
time and played the move
somewhat tricky knight to d5
my idea obviously i'm attacking the
queen
so there's no time to capture the pawn
also threatening this nice fork of the
king and the rook so the queen is a
little bit
guar has to stay around and guard so i
was expecting this position my opponent
to play maybe queen to a5
maybe queen back to d8 but probably
something like this
but in the game my opponent actually
played queen to c6
and in this position i decided to castle
um and the game went on but my opponent
managed to win however had i taken a
little more time i might have realized
something special about this position so
uh take some time if anyone in the live
audience or in the chat has suggestions
for a better move i could have played
here so white to move i've done a really
nice idea
yeah bishop b5 this is kind of a simple
one starting off kind of easy but bishop
b5 incredibly strong the queen is
trapped
queen is attacked the knight and the
bishop cover all the squares
really does a beautiful job and the only
move queen takes b5 is met with
obviously
yeah beautiful royal fork
hitting the king queen and rook
so again this is just kind of an
introductory idea but goes to show you
the power of game analysis
all right let's move on here to game
number two
all right this one happened in 2014 on
the 1st of february i was competing in a
tournament and it was my senior year so
again february of senior year i'm
thinking about graduation
also mentally preparing for the upcoming
state and national tournaments i was on
the
the chess team at vianney high school
taught by coach ed bauer shout outs
and in this game i played against a much
lower rated opponent kind of opposite of
the last time this was kind of an easy
game um didn't have a lot of difficulty
but
i analyzed it anyway because my coach
insisted that we do so we could learn
something from every game we play this
is true
and when i got around to analyzing it i
actually found a really killer move that
i'd completely overlooked again this one
might be familiar to some of you it's a
fairly common idea um but
there is something pretty cool with it
so
again i have the white pieces e4 c5 we
have a sicilian
knight to f3 knight to c6
bishop to c4 maybe a little unusual here
e5 definitely a little more unusual um
getting a lot of control over d4 but
maybe uh d6 or sorry d7 is now weakness
so something to keep an eye out for game
continues knight to c three
d6
d3
a h6
perhaps preventing knight or bishop to
g5 but
maybe it's a little slow probably
developing is a little better
i castled bishop to g4 pinning the
knights
bishop to e3 and knight to d4
in this position i played the move
i want to say yeah i just took the
knight on d4 but let's go back
again
this position
white to move and there's a much
prettier idea than what i went for in
the game so again take some time if you
need to see if you can find a better
move for white in this position
this might be a idea that's familiar to
some people
we have james duggan in the chat with
the brilliant suggestion knight to e5
and uh yeah this is the move knight
takes e5
out of nowhere bam
um
and this is really important uh this is
a pattern called legalesmate if you're
not familiar
obviously
the knight is pinned so the most obvious
move bishop takes d1 unfortunately has a
really pretty
finish
and the idea is this knight
this bishop and this knight are all
going to be able to cover a lot of
squares so after bishop takes f7 the
king only has one move
and to finish it off we have knight two
d5
checkmate super pretty um beautiful in
the middle of the board this is lee
gal's mate it's very famous very common
um i mean it doesn't happen all the time
but but it's still really pretty when it
happens
um
so but if say your opponent has seen it
this is still a good idea right because
the idea is uh if you're not taking the
queen well then you're in a rough spot
because
my my knight and queen are both
attacking your bishop
so
say you try and uh take the knight while
i just get the queen and now you've lost
a pawn
or maybe you try bishop to e6 here
probably just simply takes um
and knight takes
pawn takes is a big mistake
because of queen h5 ouch
that hurts
uh so yeah knight has to take back but
even still um in this position you're
just up a pawn a nice solid center pawn
for no compensation uh knight can
retreat safely back to f3 maybe g4 and
you have a good game from here
the previous line after queen takes g4
can led to
knight xc2
uh sorry after
queen g4
sorry knight takes
pawn takes queen g4 knight c2
uh this is interesting um we have a
counter attack on the rook i feel like
this knight
i guess maybe it can come out here maybe
it can trade for here
i'm not loving the placement of that
knight
and i am not a
2000 so i'm going to pop on my friend
stockfish here and take a look ooh
mate in six whoa
let's see if we can figure this one out
yeah what's the problem um
king is definitely exposed
so maybe
i mean bishop e5 looks like a good start
because there's nothing left here to
block
so king has to you're not going to give
it the queen so king has to move
and uh i'm not sure where the mate is
but this is already looking pretty rough
um
i i want to see it i want to see
stockfish oh i i didn't find exactly the
move but i'm still up plus a million
bishop take ah okay this makes sense
bishop takes c5 you have to block with
the queen or
yeah this is all rough we don't we don't
have to see the whole variation but
nicely it looks like a nice idea
unfortunately
again the problem is just black's not
nearly developed enough
okay
so enough with that game
let's move to the next one here
and this is another uh interesting game
this was during the semi-finals of the
gateway chess leagues high school
competition
so
semi-finals i'm playing on behalf of my
team i was bored one so trying to
represent do well
and my opponent was
i couldn't find his rating
but he was definitely stronger than i
was it was a fierce game
and he ended up winning after a 63 move
just oh it was brutal but the game was
essentially decided on move 17 and we're
going to kind of see that play out
and
so why don't we take a look at this game
here once again i have the white pieces
e4 e5 knight to f3 knight c6 and d4
scotch game pawn takes pawn and bishop
to c4 so a scotch gambit this has been
my opening repertoire for a long time so
this is still all theory
uh h6 move i'm not super familiar with
normally in this position you might see
knight f6 to attack e4 or bishop c5
trying to hang on to this pawn
so
h6 is a little unusual but it's not a
bad move just kind of waiting
so i decided to recapture the pawn and
go into some more traditional scotch
ideas queen to f6
bishop to e
or yeah bishop e3 defending the knight
bishop c5
and c3 so again fighting in the center
and my opponent decides to trade so i'm
happy with that i'm getting some nice
center pawns here
bishop retreats back to b6
i castle
d6 preparing probably to get this bishop
into the game
though it's not exactly clear where
maybe
e6 but then d5 so a little unclear
knight c3
knight to e7
rook to e1
and castles
i played the move e5 with kind of this
idea of hoping that after trades
certainly queen does not want to take on
e5 my opponent played queen 2 g6
if queen takes on e5
what's the problem here
yeah just take the bishop and it's a
discovery simple tactic okay my opponent
is not that foolish he plays queen of g6
uh we trade bishops and queen to f3
knight
rerouting here to attack our pawn and
get a little more control maybe wanting
to come to d4
rook to d1 getting the work in the game
this nice idea but unfortunately i
missed something after rook to d1 there
is the really unfortunate bishop to g4
skewer
and in this position i
just kind of shook my head and i
realized ah man what am i doing
thought for a while i thought maybe
there's something like a sacrifice or
something i could do eventually i ended
up playing rook to d6 attacking the
queen and after takes
takes
takes takes i am down in exchange i work
for a bishop that was the best i could
find
but
had i looked a little harder i might
have found something better so take a
moment and uh see if you can find the
idea i think the chat might have the
right idea but i want to give it a
little more time see if anybody else can
find a better move for white in this
position
bishop f7 also something i looked at um
probably bishop takes
yeah if queen takes then i get the
bishop but if rook takes then what's the
continuation
yeah
unfortunately it didn't really solve the
problem it was something i did consider
but i just don't think there's really
anything there for white
any other thoughts
all right i got a few other people in
the chat who are suggesting the right
move so james first and uh
shylesh i think that's your name uh well
done youtube the correct move here that
would have saved me the game at least at
this position was queen
g3
with a very subtle realization that uh
bishop d1 is a huge blunder
because uh that pawn is pinned and
that's a free queen so if i'd taken a
little bit more time a little bit more
tactical awareness maybe i would have
found this and this game really altered
my perception of chess because i'd
always thought of tactics as this thing
you play to get an advantage i never
thought is it of a tactic is something
you do to
retain uh
not not go down
so this was kind of a nice
idea for me something in my experience
of chess
this one i want to say was g40
or g45 delay five
i'm pretty sure
all right
next game here
oh
spoilers
uh this game uh was played much more
recently uh this game was actually
fought in cyberspace i played on one of
our chess.com tournaments that the chess
club hosted
and um i found myself myself facing none
other than some of you might be familiar
with michael j cummer
terrified of this opponent one of the
one of our friends here at the chess
club
and uh we played an interesting game
that i ended up winning but i could have
found a really nice idea that would have
made my job a little easier so we're
going to take a look at this and this
time i have the black pieces
we have d4 knight to f6 c4 g6 so kind of
a king's indian style defense
knight to c3 bishop to g7 e4 d6 this is
all theory
very very common ideas
and f3 so we're playing a same-x
variation here
so uh have to be aware of ideas like
pawn pushes very common in this
variation bishop e3 queen d2 a lot of
things to be aware of
kingside castle
and bishop to e3
knight to a6 this is a bit of an unusual
move by me
i play this more in the standard king's
indian lines but i was trying it out
here in the same ish and my idea is i
usually like to get this knight either
to b4 sometimes it'll come here to c5 if
d5 is ever pushed
and sometimes it'll come back to c7
after c6 or c5 so a little bit of an
interesting idea i just wanted to see
how mike would respond
and we have queen to d2 just really
simply aiming to trade off these bishops
e5
d5
and knight to c5
bishop to h6 and
so again looking to trade off the
bishops most of you will know this but
anytime you're in a position where
there's an opponent is castled with a
fiance bishop trading off that bishop is
going to provoke weaknesses so in the
game i played a5 and i don't remember if
he took the bishop but let's imagine he
does
maybe right away is not the best idea
but even still
weaknesses are being provoked in the
dark squares here so something to be
aware
of go back so i played a5 thinking all
right he's going to fight here on the
king side i'll fight on the queen side
and we'll just see who's faster
but
in this position actually again had a
better move so this is maybe a little
more
tricky but
take some time see if you can find a
really cool idea for black here
um
really nice move
that again someone in the chat looks
like arnie might be seeing but i'll give
our audience everybody else some time so
again black to move and find a really
nice idea
see if anyone can come up with it
all right i see a few people in the chat
anyone that live studios want to give it
a shot
uh knight h5 definitely an interesting
move uh very common idea in the kings
indian or sometimes 98 as well with the
idea that
you can actually fight back on the king
side um in the same ish i'm not as
familiar with how that battle goes but
it's a common idea wanting to play f5
and continue to fight that way
definitely an idea but i don't think
here it's going to give you anything
immediate sorry someone else
to c4
oh knight to e4 not c4
yeah e is right here
yeah knight e4 and a few people in the
chat have said it so shylesh tariq and
[ __ ] the trail hobo awesome uh yeah i
think both of them can do it but knight
f is better
and the idea is
after pawn takes what else right the
queen is hit so you don't have time to
trade or do anything else you can take
with the knight but i mean why would you
they're giving you a piece
queen h4
and now you've given up the knight but
you've gotten a center pawn and you're
going to win the piece back plus the
piece you're winning here
is this uh really important bishop and
now your defenses are just solidified uh
you could take uh yeah i guess if they
play g6 you have to take here with the
queen um they can exchange or not but
either way you're very happy with this
setup
um keeping a hold of your dark squared
bishop and there's immediately threats
of f5 and maybe bishop takes if they
capture so really nice position
um
where
if they like exchange here
oh right right here
yeah unfortunately there's not enough
time because the knight's hitting the
queen
yeah so you either have to take it with
the pawn or the knight um
if
i mean i guess you could take with the
knight but the problem is now you're
just
losing even more um
so yeah
and yeah someone in the chat's asking if
knight c e4 works as well i think it
doesn't because the main idea is to get
this check and your knight's still going
to be in the way here
so good question um
okay
next game
all right
this is another cyberspace game uh this
is just against an anonymous opponent so
i don't have too much story to tell but
it was last year and there's just a nice
pretty tactical idea i thought i would
share with everybody here so uh i have
the white side and we have a french
defense
yeah
uh here in the chat
sorry about that yep
um yes we have a french defense and
knight d2 the tarash variation
uh main idea here is if you play knight
to c3 you're accepting the possibility
that bishop b4 is coming this is the
winner variation it's very common very
theoretical and a little bit annoying
so i play knight d2
obviously this doesn't work because of
c3
so we have an exchange and knight to f6
knight takes and queen takes f6
knight to f3
and bishop to d6
and now i play bishop to g5 trying to
get some nice tempo here
queen goes to f5 and bishop to
d3
so again my pieces are much more active
in this position getting a lot of tempo
on this queen
queen to a5 check but i just bring the
bishop back and queen goes to d5 but
it's not done yet
c4
just really enjoying every bit of
initiative i can take against this queen
and now the queen moves back here to c6
and in this position uh i played the
move queen to c sorry i played castles
uh and then a6 and then rook e1
castles and now queen of c2 yeah queen
ec2 with the idea of crowing this
battery against the king side
and this is still a good move again
because i got so much initiative on the
queen these pieces are horribly
misplaced this knight has nowhere to go
this bishop has nowhere to go so a
definitely better position regardless
after queen c2 but there is a kind of
unique idea a little
fun one for white
so once again i'll ask you to turn your
tactical brains on see if you can find a
better idea for white
bishop h7 you're going for a greek gift
okay well let's see if you can do it um
obviously king h8 not great because
knight g5
and uh i mean i guess you could try and
play this out but queen is coming to h5
and
it's not going to be fun so we'll look
at a better idea
if we accept it what's the continuation
knight g5 and now king has four options
um
probably the worst i think definitively
the worst is king h8
uh can anyone finish this game real
quick
yeah queen h5 and h7 and this is over so
you don't want to go back to h8
maybe we can do a little better
h6
still not good but maybe it's a little
bit better
there is a problem here a real big one
though
yes but where should we put this knight
what do you think
uh f7 is definitely a spot um double
check
um
really there's not losing moves here f7
is good
if you want to go to e6 and get the rook
like really everything you play is fine
uh i actually like knight e4 here
um with the idea that after like
i mean i guess the king can go back but
you're going to run into queen h5 real
quick so
after something like g5
and queen of g4
this is going to get really ugly really
quick there's no time to play f5 because
queen takes
so f6 defending
but just bishop takes
and uh yeah this is
not pleasant for the player the black
pieces
rookie three
and there's really no way to stop mate
at this point um i mean you can delay it
play e5 and prevent rook there but then
just queen h5
and rook to g3 so
uh
yeah unfortunately h6 isn't going to be
a good move either
the best move here is king g6 but we'll
look at one more if king to g8
how should we continue this for the
white side
still queen h5 and now um to prevent
checkmate uh best move probably is rook
to d8 giving the king a little breathing
room so from here where
f7 yeah this is important uh h7 is still
good
but not nearly as forcing
queen f7 first
and then
back to h5
uh-huh and all of these moves are forced
the king only has one move
yep again one move only
and
just beautiful
all forcing moves
all the way there so that's a fun little
calculating one if you want to test
yourself
all those moves just one move so really
pretty there okay so let's go back
and let's give our opponent the best
shot with king to g6 uh this is
to be fair if you were playing in a game
and your opponent has their king on g6
you're probably in a good position um
especially with these many pieces on the
board
so how should we continue from here to
get the best advantage
a little harder obviously point of king
g6 is preventing queen h5 so
what else can we do to retain some
tactical advantage
h4 definitely an idea
probably good enough as well um
queen g4 another idea um
i think someone in the chat suggesting
rook e3
lots of good moves here um
it's really hard to lose in this kind of
position uh move i would place probably
queen g4 just the most direct threat um
and
opponent's probably gonna play f5 e5
looks really nice
because it's getting this discovery so
obviously you can't move the knight or
else you'll lose the queen but this
doesn't work due to something very
unfortunate
what's the problem with e5 here
yeah just brutal
just brutal cutting off the bishop
maintaining the discovery
and yeah the king has got nowhere good
to go
this is going to be over very soon and
now important move here bishop we need
it to maintain some control of these
dark squares we're going to put it on d8
force the king into the corner
and that if they go to h7 it's just made
in one but here it's made in two
so kind of nice idea there so yeah e5
doesn't work
f5 a little stronger try trying to give
the king some wiggle room to escape
but there is a way to stop this from
working
anyone find the best idea for white
yeah queen h4 uh very very simple point
is we want to go to h7
and
there's not really anything you can do
to stop us um
with some help from the computer uh
looked like queen takes c4 there's just
no attempt over here and then you can
even be a little mean and play something
like rook to c1
because again you just have time
queen h7
king moves
and now how do we finish it from here
there's lots of ways to do it but
if anyone has any ideas i'm open
uh rookie three
yeah we're giving up a bishop to do that
and we have to be careful of
not getting back ranked but there might
be time um
we have someone in the chat saying queen
h6 that's pretty crazy
i don't know if that works
but maybe
i think probably
the simplest way is just to play a
really calm and quiet knight f3
we're defending our bishop and we're
more importantly opening up g5 for the
bishop
um because we really want to keep the
king from escaping onto these dark
squares
but there's lots of options here
black could continue again the computer
doesn't really know what to do there's
not a lot of good moves so if we just
try and develop at night um
kind of we could just play bishop g5
right away and that's fine uh again the
computer is kind of mean wants to play
oh whoops
rook to d1 first
just to say well i want your queen and
there's really not much you can do uh
even after queen to c2 you still just
play this move and now the rook's in a
slightly better position i suppose is
the point
um
and yeah this is just about over let's
maybe look at one more move white to
move and play really the strongest move
here
bishop h6 just really brutal uh hitting
this pawn there's not any good way you
can defend it also opening up back for
the knight to come back to g5 so the
knight moved out of the way to let the
bishop come in and now it wants to come
back
there's no ideas of rook to g8 because
knight g5 is gonna eventually force the
king away um you can probably just take
here anyway and get some nice
finishing ideas we don't really have to
analyze this in too much in depth but i
think you get the idea that
uh yeah queen g6 it's there's really
nothing i mean maybe there's like 98 but
nothing's going to last long
there's going to be a really good way to
finish it
so
okay
enough with that kind of fun one but
just i guess to kind of go back to it
this is not something i've experienced
often in my games the opportunity for a
greek gift so it's nice to be aware of
them when when you have the chance
all right one more
online game here
and then uh i have two kind of really
fun ones i want to show you
all right so this game
i had white and we have another
interesting idea and this
opening was actually i learned it from
the chess club's very own jonathan
trance if you know it you know it
but it is time
for the nakmansen
oh if you've never seen it let me
introduce you to this dubious wonder of
knight to c3 so normally in this
position again we have kind of a scotch
gambit
knight to f6 main idea and takes and
usually what you'll see here is rook to
e1 this is the anderson attack lots of
theory here d5 defending the knight
attacking the bishop and kind of a
pretty move bishop takes on d5
after the queen takes
knight to c3
pawn is pinned the knight is pinned
everything is pinned uh queen has to
move and you're gonna take the knight
and the game can continue bishop e6 is a
move bishop b7
if you don't play one of those you have
to be really careful because knight to
d6 is coming so
this is very common but we have
enactments in which is one of my
favorite chess openings
knight to c3 right away it looks
terrible and it probably is but
it's very very fun very very venomous
and in the game my opponent played
knight take c3 so this is a declined
variation
d takes is the main move and probably
the most critical but this is still a
very sensible move uh magnus carlsen has
faced enactments in several times and
this is one of the ways he actually
prefers to to play against it so
if carlson is playing something you've
got to treat it with respect
except maybe the bomb cloud all right
uh rook to e1
bishop e7 and now we recapture the
knight and my opponent played uh pawn
takes back which is a little bit greedy
and in this position
i uh forgot a little bit of my theory
and played the second best move
uh i played queen to d5
and this looks very menacing but it
unfortunately doesn't work um now it
happened to work for me
in the game my opponent castled what
else
i guess maybe rook fade is a move but
that's a little sketchy so he just
castled
and knight to g5
and in the game my opponent made a
mistake
he played the move bishop takes g5 which
is losing on the spot after bishop takes
g5 and the queen is trapped
and that's rough and there's no ideas of
f6 because the pawn is pinned
so
yeah that's pretty rough um i think my
opponent just resigned in this position
but there actually is a better way to
survive this after knight to g5 so first
we're going to look and see what my
opponent could have done better and then
we'll figure out what i could have done
better so instead of bishop takes here
anyone have a suggestion for the only
surviving move
for black in this position
i can flip the board if you want black
to move and play the only move that
keeps you in the game
uh queen eight looks tempting i think
the problem is gonna be
this this bishop yeah i think probably
there might be ideas of like bishop a3
um
you can
i'm not convinced in it i think
i don't know exactly what a refutation
might be but i'm willing to check
um
yeah this feels like it could be a
little problematic i'm honestly thinking
of maybe bishop a3 and after d6 there
might be some ideas of
like sacking a rook and bringing
something in
i'm not 100 sure it's definitely an
interesting idea um
a knight before is actually the only
move
the night before and the game is
the stockfish just says this is a draw
this is dead draw completely even
um
and it's a really interesting idea the
best move for white from stock fish in
this position
is actually to play queen takes f7
it says this is the only way to stay in
the game um and after rook takes so
there's two moves here
well rook takes and then knight takes
and in this position there's two moves
you can either play you can either save
your queen
or the only other move stock visual play
is king f8
so if you play the obvious move
then simply we can repeat
and this is a draw
um
so if you don't want that you can play
king f8
uh
obviously a bishop back to b3 stopping
the fork and stockfish also says this is
an even game it's just dead even zero
zero uh
turn on the engine
it's going to think for a second but
eventually it'll be like nah this is
even
um
and if it's a very interesting position
if people want to analyze this further
that's fine
maybe this is going to be a famous
endgame one day
but probably not because i actually had
a better move remember
so let's go back
so in this position i played queen to d5
and hoped for a really nice easy victory
there's actually a much better move here
what's a better way for white to press
the advantage
uh bishop f7
in some lines with enactments and you do
here
it might work but i think we've probably
given up too much king takes
and what's your thought maybe
queen d5
uh
well problem with knight now is this
bishop's not pinned anymore
so like knight g5 i don't think is gonna
work um
knight e5 is obviously covered by uh
this knight i think black's just gonna
have enough resources to defend
so interesting idea but it's actually
something a little better here
i think someone in the chat has it here
i think uh shailesh i'm going to give it
to you
knight g5 right away
and the problem is obviously can't take
uh problem is after castles
queen h5
and it looks like you still might be
okay after uh well so bishop takes
doesn't work because we've already
looked and this is the same trap
but it looks like he might be okay after
h6
but h6 does not in fact work
problem here is knight takes f7 and
there's just too much attacking the
attacking this square too much control
so a few variations i don't want to get
too bogged down because i have a fun
game i want to show you
if something like queen to e8 maybe then
just knight h6
and this is going to be
over very quickly
if instead
rook takes
then just bishop takes
threatening mate
so you have to defend it and how do you
defend it
not a lot of great options here
if uh if knight to e5 you just take it
doesn't save anything
and if the obvious move queen e8
what's the problem with this anybody see
it
yeah queen five um simple enough um
bishop to f6
and then
yeah well you can uh you can take the
queen and you're just winning but
there's a little bit of a sweeter way i
want to show you how this game could end
queen takes f6 just for style points and
after pawn takes bishop h6
really pretty really fun so but yeah
quit taking the queen is just fine
you're going to win that game anyway but
had to show this too pretty
okay
um
so
those are kind of the isolated puzzles
but if you remember i talked about chess
as
a narrative as a story and so i want to
tell you a story of really the most
impactful chess game i played
and this is a game i played against
uh women's grandmaster anna sherivich i
played this back in 2012 and this was
the first game i'd ever played against a
title player so if any of you have had
that experience of your first game you
probably can remember the first time you
played someone and you saw nm or gm or w
anything like that and we're just like
this is
horrific this is terrifying and it's
exhilarating um and so i was playing
against anna in a simul there were
like about 20 other people um and this
was back in 2012. it was a cold blustery
day it was october it was almost
halloween and uh rightly so i was
terrified but it was a super fun game so
i want to kind of walk you through the
game and then we'll take some analytical
look in these last
20 minutes or so
so in the game i had the white pieces
and i played e4
and my opponent
played c5 we have a sicilian c3
we have a c3 or aleppin sicilian and
knight f6 is the main line
and all of my preparation when i'm
sitting across the table from a wgm just
walking around the room casually playing
moves all of my preparation went out the
window and i realized i don't want to
lose this pawn and i played d3
this is a move it's not very good e5 is
the main move
but
you know when you're sitting against a
title player for the first time i was a
sophomore in high school i just i didn't
want to lose a pawn so this is the move
i played
e5 and i'm thinking okay this is a bit
unexpected um
we saw earlier that this can be a little
weakening of the d-pawn but certainly
there's a lot of pressure here on the d4
square
so knight f3 kind of provoking that
seeing if this pawn is coming up or
what's going to happen knight c6
bishop to e2 and d5 and so now pressure
is also on e4 square
so i have to be managing that
i played bishop to g5 to remove that
pressure
a little bit and after bishop e7
i
played queen to b3 and i had an idea
that i saw there's a threat on e4 but i
thought maybe i have a counter attack
d takes e4 and bishop takes f6
so this was my idea and i thought okay
if d takes f3 then i'm attacking the
queen and you don't have time
so after something like queen or knight
takes e7 bishop takes and i felt this
was a playable position i have kind of
an attack on this b7 pawn and i can
continue from here now i'm overlooking
some things we'll get back to it chad i
know you're going to be screaming at me
but i will come back to it
um but this is just the story this is to
give you the to paint the picture
so bishop f6 and my opponent uh actually
kind of respected this idea and played
bishop takes f6 herself
and now i take back on d4 on e4 i should
say and again feeling okay maybe
the d4 square is pretty weak but gonna
do what i can
my opponent castles and i castle queen
to e7
knight b to d2
bishop to e6 attacking the queen and
queen to c2
rook fd8 rook fd1 rook a to c8 we're
just getting our pieces involved and i
decided to play knight to c4 wanting to
reroute here to e3
and a very important idea so b5 which
actually allows me to do this
knight to e3 and c4 and now i play
knight to d5
forcing black to give up the bishop pair
uh you're either gonna take here or i'm
gonna take one of uh your queen or your
bishop so uh my opponent decided to take
and i played e takes d5 and now i have a
passed pawn and i'm thinking okay
maybe i'm in a worse position but i have
a passport i have something to hope for
uh at this point probably half of the
players have already lost so the room is
getting quieter and it's the tension is
rising
uh knight to b8
and i played b3 which looks okay i'm
trying to challenge here on
the queen side but unfortunately i
missed this move e4
unleashing the bishop
pretty strong attack
um and so now i got to be careful and
there's also obviously threats of c
takes b3 and the rook getting in the
game so my position is a little
precarious
i played knight to d2
and e3 a strong move uh
and i didn't want to take back here f
takes e3 looked pretty scary so i
decided to just bring my knight back to
e4
and e takes f2
and knight takes f2
king f1 i did consider but
i don't want to go down pawns against
the wgm not my intention
uh queen to e3
and i also didn't want to trade queens i
thought
she's going to be much better with her
minor pieces than i am if i have queens
on the board maybe complications she's
playing a bunch of other games maybe i'm
okay
but
i i couldn't find another move and i
desperately i wanted to stay in the game
so i just played queenie four it's the
only thing i could see
rookie 8 and we
trade bishop to g4 rook to d8
rook a to c1 just getting out of the pin
i'm not going to save this pawn i know
that but
i'm doing what i can bishop takes c3
okay
a lot going on and i'm thinking what am
i going to do
and i realized the only thing that i
have really going for in this position
that i can hold on hope for is this past
pawn so
i'm going to push it
here we go
d6
knight to c6 this does allow the knight
back into the game and it's good square
but i'm okay with that i played rook to
d5 maybe thinking of doubling also uh
maybe eventually attacking b5
c takes b3 a takes b3
and knight to e7 a nice idea
it looks like
this is maybe a problem but after pawn
takes pawn
rook takes this doesn't work the rook is
covering the square so
no bueno uh not good and i can't even
like take this bishop here because of
this
so i there's really no compensation
there
um so i i thought about it and i thought
okay i'll play here rook takes b5 with
the idea now that um there's a little
bit of a problem
you can't take this pawn because now i
have a back rank
so i'm defending my pawn indirectly and
getting rid of one of yours feeling okay
about this
knight to g6 and now i play d7 and my
bishop is come alive saving this pawn
and i have kind of a sneaky idea that
i'm hoping to enact the next few moves
knight to e5 forking bishop and pawn
but i play rook to c5 uh hitting the
bishop first
knight takes g4
and instead of taking back this bishop
which i think is also good i played rook
to c8
love this tactical idea i actually used
this uh
this was played sophomore year but i
used this against a senior member of my
uh chess team i think freshman year the
same idea and he got so frustrated he
kept being like let's go back a few
moves and try and he kept trying to beat
it and he couldn't find a way to avoid
it he was very flustered and as this
pawn got closer and closer i kept
thinking wait a minute maybe i can maybe
i can do this
okay so now i'm thinking i have a chance
this is something real
bishop to a5 defending the rook
knight takes g4 recapturing my piece
and rook to e7
i played rook to d1 so complicated game
um i looked at rook takes d8 bishop
takes
rook c8 and rook takes d7
and i just couldn't find a way to
make use of this pin i don't think the
knight's quite fast enough i think the
king's gonna be able to get there
and so i was like okay this looks good
but not good enough i need to hold on to
my past pawn it's my hope
so rook d1
uh bishop b6 check and i'm bringing my
king to f1
king to f8 then i play rook to d6
h5
and i stopped and i thought about this
position for a while
i eventually played knight to f2
and my opponent played g6 and in this
position
i considered an idea that i thought
would be
i thought it would lead me to a winning
end game but
i was the last person in the room
against this wgm all the other games had
finished and so instead of having time
where she's walking around and playing
some moves she is standing across the
table looking at me and i'm just feeling
the pressure and i'm thinking okay i
could probably get into a winning end
game against wgm
i'm not going to win a winning end game
against the wgm and i offered a draw
and she accepted
so i took a draw i was very happy with
that the variation i saw
was rook takes b6
with the idea that i'm removing the
defender of this rook
uh so after rook takes d7
rook d8 rook d8
and i have a knight for a pawn that's
pretty good
this is i was not confident enough maybe
i could have gone for it but i didn't
that's my story
and now in the last 10 minutes
let's do a little more analysis of it
because there are some really
interesting points in this game that are
worth talking about
that is if i can get my mouse in the
right spot
all right let's jump back up to the
beginning
okay
i'm going to breeze through the
beginning a little bit e4 c5 c3 again i
freak out play d3 don't play the main
line which is e5 and then you can have
like knight t4 c takes d4
you can take back i play knight f3
because i mean you can't take this
you're just giving up a knight so
um this is a very common idea but i
didn't i played d3 e5 knight f3 knight
c6 these moves all make sense we
understand them bishop to g5 bishop e7
and queen to b3 and again my plan
thinking
this doesn't work you can't take my pawn
because i'm going to take your knight
there's a problem here
my opponent played bishop f6 but better
anybody what's the better move for black
here
again my idea was that i'm going to take
this bishop and threaten the queen so
there's no time to take on f3 but there
is an idea that's good for black that i
missed
uh
pawn d3 is interesting um i don't think
it's good enough because i'm still just
going to take the bishop and attack the
queen
and are you thinking like maybe d2 i
mean my knights are covering
actually you can still just take on f3
and what i missed was
after bishop takes
pawn takes on g2
and uh i can take your queen and you're
gonna get a brand new one fresh out the
gate for my rook so that's not ideal i
missed that luckily my opponent didn't
see it
okay
we continue the game goes on i haven't
lost yet
we castle queen e7 knight bd2 bishop b6
attacking the queen queen c2 all this is
good rook fd8 rook fd1 rook 8 c8
and i played knight c4 the computer
doesn't love this because there's a
really crazy idea coming up b5 knight e3
again my opponent in this position
played c4 and i was able to get this
nice situation where i forced a bishop
trade but there is a better move for
black a kind of crazy move for black
can anyone find it if you can i'm amazed
but i want to see about it
so black to move the move in the game
was c4
but there's a really crazy move that i
just didn't consider at all and my
opponent didn't find
but it's worth looking at
knight d4 are you insane how did you
find that what's what's the idea
yeah so we're going to unleash this rook
and it's going to be a little awkward
right you're going to win my the piece
back and now you've also just really
opened the center so really cool idea
this is a little difficult to navigate
and yeah i feel like black's better
you've opened up the space you've
maintained the bishop pair so kind of
cool idea one that i hadn't considered
all right
so we go back to our game knight d5
bishop takes d5
e takes knight b8 and b3 again a mistake
because it's allowing this idea after e4
knight d2 e3
and again i said f takes e3 didn't look
good i was right
this is really rough
this is really really rough
uh you're hitting the rook you're
hitting the knight and
maybe eventually you just want to come
back here and call checkmate so yeah
this is unfortunate um so knight e4
better idea
knight takes f2
queen to e3
i trade queens which was the best idea
so nothing wrong there
and we do trade bishop g4 hitting the
knight or hitting the rook i should say
d6 and knight c6
and rook d5 this is not the best move
um
it's got a bit of a problem i believe
i think or anything so yeah my opponent
played c takes p3 but there's a much
better move here
um
black to move and play the best move so
again see if you can figure this one out
rick d5 was not optimal it creates a
problem
that i would not have been able to deal
with
uh 94
knight b4
yeah knight b4 looks pretty good um
probably also good enough
uh even stronger though
is bishop to b2
and the idea
is this pawn is coming to c3
very simple but how do you stop it um
so rook moves pawn to c3 and it's hard
to actually stop this from promoting it
is not trivial at all
so possible continuation could be like
work to c5 hitting the knight in the
pawn and now knight jumps in
um
it's kind of a pretty sacrifice square
because you can't you can't let it get
here um
so just one sample continuation
but you're not going to be able to stop
this
that's really the best you can do
okay don't get too dragged down with
this one because there's
something at the end that i want to look
at
okay so back to our game
a3 and knight e7 was the move again this
is a mistake
i did rook takes b5 which is still good
but there's actually an even better move
here as well
if you remember the problem right the
problem here is i want to take and
promote but this rook is covering
the promotion square so you're just
going to take this but there's a way to
kind of resolve that issue so can anyone
see a better move for white here
then
then rook takes b5 something better
rook takes bishop looks good but uh just
loses
i love that bishop that's a cool
sacrifice idea if i wasn't checkmated
so
the idea here
is again we want to
rook c5 is a good move so tariq just
said in the chat rook c5 that's another
good move here um
but the move that is even stronger
rook d3
because we want to draw this rook off
this line
um we want to keep it from guarding the
promotion square
so
if after rook c3
you could play something like rookie
five and keep it on the line but then
we're just gonna take this
and you don't have time to take
because of this
so instead
you could go let me go back here
if you take this rook it doesn't work
either
because i take the knight
and i'm either taking this or promoting
and i'm getting the rook back
so again not ideal
okay
one more tactic to kind of wrap this one
up and we'll call it a night
knight to g6 d7 95 rook c5 remember i'm
battling for my life i find this really
cool idea bishop a5
knight takes g4 rookie
7. rook d1
bishop b6 king f1 king f8 so close so
close
rook d6
h5
and knight f2
instead of playing knight f2 here uh
remember i showed you this kind of rook
takes b6 idea it still works here
um
but again my idea was i still didn't
think this was going to be worth it
because we're going to take and i'm
going to have a knight for a pawn again
in an end game and this isn't going to
be enough but i missed something i
missed that after
rook takes d7
i have a better idea there's a better
move here
can you see something better than uh
than what was played in the game
or i just wanted to trade rooks but
there's something even better
we have 95 suggested in the chat
that's really interesting move
i feel like it's probably not gonna work
because literally everything is hanging
but maybe
um
i think a better move here is rook to b8
and we're doubling up and threatening to
take so you have to play uh i mean if
you play here
then
then i can just trade everything
and i just have a knight but this is a
better position i would be very
comfortable with this if there's a rook
on the board that's not as good but if i
just have a knight i can be fine
so the other idea is to go for checks
but you can just run away
we're going to have to hide but we can
eventually do it and then get this same
position and we just have a night
and
if you are in this position uh and you
are not a beginner then even you can
beat a women's grandmaster i believe uh
maybe not maybe i still would have been
a draw but at least it would have been a
better story
okay
so that's really all i have um but
hopefully just looking through these
games you've been a little reminded of
the power of narrative and chess and
again each move is telling a story uh
the game the environment it's all a
story and it's all really interesting
and we can all learn from analyzing our
game so that's one of the big lessons
big takeaways for me it has been a
pleasure and an honor to share these
games with you so i sincerely thanks
offer my thanks to all of you in the
audience and everybody joining online so
do stay tuned in for insanely end game
coming up next with gm brian smith so as
always my name is alex mullering and i
hope to see you again on the road to
2000
[Music]
you